la junta de Educación del estado de la
Florida ha aprobado expandir a grados
Superiores de las escuelas en la
polémica ley del no digas gay que
prohíbe expresamente hablar sobre
condición sexual o identidad de género
en las escuelas públicas del Estado
desde el grado 4 al 12 es decir hasta
los 18 años de edad esta nueva regla que
por cierto no requiere de una aprobación
legislativa forma parte de los esfuerzos
que ha estado haciendo el gobernador de
Florida el republicano ron de santis en
los últimos tiempos para llevar a cabo
una agenda mucho más conservadora con
medidas como esta o también con la
restricción del aborto a las 6 semanas
de gestación entre otras cosas la nueva
regulación prohíba expresamente que los
maestros brinden elecciones sobre estas
cuestiones de identidad de género A
menos que la instrucción sea requerida
por los estándares estatales o sea parte
de una clase de salud de la que los
Padres pueden decidir si sus hijos
participen o no la violación de la regla
podría resultar en la suspensión o
incluso la revocación de la licencia de
enseñanza de un educador Ya el año
pasado el gobernador de santis apoyó una
ley de este tipo pero dirigida a los
niños de hasta nueve años la medida ya
en ese entonces creó una gran
controversia entre los grupos lgbtq
Incluso el presidente de Estados Unidos
o Joe biden se ha mostrado en contra
porque considera que es una regla
discriminatoria pero detrás de todo esto
estarían las intenciones del gobernador
de Florida para presentarse a las
primarias en republicanas de Cara a las
elecciones presidenciales de 2024 a
pesar de que él aún no ha confirmado sus
intenciones